take me just a moment to get us set up
on youtube and then i'll give you the
go-ahead
as christina's doing that you all should
uh
say good morning to christina daya she's
our committee researcher and she's going
to be helping us through the zoom
and as we go through our sessions this
year
hi everyone okay you're all set
okay thank you christina as chair of the
house
municipal and county government
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covert 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee orientation meeting
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting
complies with house rules and rsa
91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600
or email hcs at
dot leg.state.nh dot u s in the event
the public is unable to access the
meeting the meeting will be adjourned
and rescheduled
christina dyer our committee researcher
will be the staff assisting us
please note that all votes taken during
this meeting
will be done using the roll call vote
let's start by taking a roll call
attendance
normally this in the future will be done
by the
committee clerk but i'm going to do it
today
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there's
anybody in the room with you during the
meeting which is required under the
right to no
use our longer to create positive change
in our community
now as for keller the 38 year old is now
charged with obstructing law enforcement
knowingly
it is going great
i just did it we're good thank you
all right when i call your name just
answer here or president also
uh where you are and if there's anybody
in the room with you
uh representative piamonte
you have to unmute yourself when i call
on your name
yes i'm here by myself
representatives davis
present on a loan representative porter
president and a cat might wander in okay
representative maturi president i'm
alone in my office
representative mcdonald
i am present at my house and alone
okay representative i am present and uh
my cat's here
representative gilman
representative tripp president alone
representative guthrie
representative lasalles
i'm here in litchfield with all my
friends
i have no friends representative
representative mcbride
representative melvin here by myself
representative ayer
year alone representative power
yes here i'm alone in my office however
i have two family members in other parts
of the house
okay and by the way if uh for those
folks i have not met yet if i
mispronounce
your name i apologize in advance please
correct me how you want me to say it
representative majipudi
uh representative manji puti i am you
did it
close you i'm at home by myself
representative vann
representative vann you have to unmute
yourself
she can't unmute okay got it got it i'm
on a phone because my computer stopped
working
i am here and i am by myself
okay thank you representative klee
i am here i am currently alone in this
room but my husband will be walking
around
and i have two greyhounds that will make
a presentation at some point
they always do okay representative
gallagher
uh hi i'm here and i'm alone
okay and i'm representative dolan and
i'm alone also
in londonderry now let me go back uh in
case somebody joined us late
representative mcbride are you here
representative guthrie
or representative gilman
okay just for uh introduction purposes
representative piamonte is the vice
chair
and representative mcdonald is our clerk
so in the future the clerk will be
taking role
uh not only for attendance but also for
a vote
all right now that we've got that out of
the way
although this may seem a little awkward
i'd like to say the pledge
uh so if if you could if i could ask you
to stand and if you don't have a flag
that's visible to you i'll hold one up
and we can say the pledge together
[Music]
with liberty thank you
i said i know that might have been a
little awkward but i think it's
important
so what i'd like to do first is
is go through each of the
of the members and have
stop stop sorry
we'll do each of the members and have
them introduce themselves and say a
little bit about themselves
uh please keep it short and
hopefully many of us are attorneys on
this committee but
some are new and some are also new to
the legislature so
this is a good chance to introduce
yourself and help us get to know each
other
so let me start my name is tom dolan
um this year i'm going to be the
chairman of the committee
this is my second term in the
legislature
i've been in municipal government as a
town counselor
or budget committee member for about 20
years
here in londonderry i have
two grown children and they're often
married having babies themselves
and uh i look forward to our
relationship
uh developing over the next couple of
years and
and enjoying this assignment this is i
found a very fulfilling assignment and
we have
a lot of direct impacts to our to our
home communities
and with that turn it over to tony
okay my name is tony pimarti this is my
second year in the
municipal county i come from sandown
that's
rockingham district four and
that's where i live and i'm retired so
plenty plenty of time okay thanks tony
uh representatives davis
yeah sorry about that uh good morning
i'm laurel stavis i'm in my second term
in the house
and my second term on municipal and
county government
i am a long time member of the lebanon
new hampshire planning board
chair of listen community services board
of directors and also a member of the
west lebanon revitalization committee
so municipal affairs kind of
are in my wheelhouse and i love this
committee
and i'm looking forward to serving on it
again
thank you representative porter who by
the way is the
the ranking member those of you not
familiar with that terminology
the ranking member is the member of the
committee that has been selected
by the by the minority leadership
to be the senior member on the committee
good morning i'm marjorie porter this is
my sixth term in the house
and my fourth term on municipal and
county
one of which i served as the chair
another i served as the clerk so
i've been here a while um i'm a retired
teacher
i've taught in public schools and
private schools and ran my
own kindergarten preschool for about 12
years or so before
i retired i'm retired now um
gratefully and homebound
and i'm looking forward to this year
it's a very non-partisan committee and
that's what makes it so good to be here
thank you uh representative maturi
thank you mr chair uh my name is jim
majorie representing
rockingham district 22 which is
northampton
this is my second term in the house and
second second term on municipal and
county government
and echo what many others have said i
truly enjoyed my
my first term on municipal and county
government we have a
a good group of people got along well
and i think we were very productive
which is important to me because i also
serve
as i'm in my fourth term as a selectman
in northampton
from which i also serve on the planning
board the heritage commission the water
commission
so municipal affairs are are very very
important to me
and i am also a board member on
the new hampshire municipal association
so i look forward to working with all of
you and hope for a great progress this
year thank you
thanks jim and our clerk
representative mcdonald
make sure you're off mute john
i still s you're still showing on mute
there you go
how about now okay good morning everyone
my name is uh john mcdonald
uh i live up in wolfman new hampshire
this is my second term in the
legislature my second uh
tmr municipal county government and i
think it's a great committee
have a look good folks and we all seem
to get along which is which is great
thank you thanks john uh representatives
trulevent
good morning again all this is my fourth
term in the legislature
and my fourth term on municipal and
county government
my profession is real estate i'm a real
estate broker so
munim municipal affairs county affairs
land is beneath all is very important to
me
i've really enjoyed working on this
committee um
i'm the parent of two i'm the
grandparent of two
and uh i look forward to getting to know
some of you better
and those of you who i know already more
deeply thank you very much
thank you representative tripp
good morning uh i'm a vietnam vet
spent eight years in the navy and uh
decided there was a better way to live
than that
this is uh my second term i was
interrupted uh
by one term i true am a uh municipal and
county veteran i served one term on
previously
uh i uh
i've been a town counselor in derry for
uh
six years hopefully going on nine
uh i'm also on the planning board and
other
sundry boards it seems like once you get
busy in municipal government then
they drag you into everything so uh
i enjoyed my last term and i hope i
enjoy this term
thank you thank you representative
loseless
yes my name is uh rich lasales this is
my
third term in the house i'm
a 10-year veteran of the navy uh
submarine service uh i
have been serving in my first term as a
selectmen here in litchfield
hillsborough 20. previously i was on the
state federal affairs of veterans
affairs committee
i enjoyed that and i look forward to my
service
here in
representative melvin take yourself off
mute first
can you hear me yeah go ahead thank you
okay i'm representative
charles melvin from newton uh district
15.
i spent 30 years on the planner board i
spent 15 years on the zoning board of
adjustments
uh i'm a second term selectman
and i'm a member of the school board
uh representative um
hi my name is paul ayer it's my first
term
i represent raymond district three and
i'm retired
thank you representative power
thank you mr chair good morning everyone
my name is
diane power i am a freshman state rep
i've lived in new hampshire for 32 years
and in brookline for 27 years i
represent hillsborough county
district 26 brookline and mason
i have two adult children formerly i was
the the chair and member of the hollis
brookline cooperative
school district budget committee and i
look forward to serving with you all on
this committee
thank you thanks representative
manjuputi
namaste i am fifth
term in state legislation i've served
previously
on school board and i'm on hillsborough
county
executive board and i've served in
criminal justice and public safety
committee
to first two terms and state federal and
veterans affairs
the second two terms and this is my
first term i'm so looking forward to
being part of this committee and i'm a
serial entrepreneur
so i have consulting companies and
this is public service is my passion
looking forward to
thank you representative van
representative i am yeah i have done
mute myself
uh did i'm ivy van i live in
peterborough
um i am this is my fourth term in the
house
i served initially on fish and game
because that was the day of the week
that i had come
it was fascinating i chose on
transportation for one term and last
term i
served on public works and highways
i'm a certified urban planner by the
certified by the american planning
association
and i am working right now
with the american association of retired
persons and the congress for the new
urbanism
to do some work for
uh jurisdictions across the country
making their places
better for everyone particularly as it
as
it uh involves in increasing housing
accessibility
and i'm happy to be here great thank you
representative klee
thank you hi um i'm uh from nashua this
is my
third term my previous two terms i was
on the state fed actually sorry state
fed relations and veterans affairs
last year i served as the chair for that
committee
i'm retired from 26 years of working
with the
department of veterans affairs i'm owned
i have no children but i'm owned by two
greyhounds
um let's see i i do a lot of volunteer
work with the united way
and i'm also a two-term alderman here in
nashua
thank you okay and last but not least
representative gallagher
hi i'm eric gallagher um
i'm i live in ward 6 here
in concord um which is merrimack
um county district 15. i live in public
housing
and so that made me interested in
housing as an issue
and i heard that
this committee um is the
one that deals with housing issues
um so that's why i play as one of my
choices
and um this is my first term
okay thank you representative dolan
um we did have some um other additional
reps show up we have um
representative mcbride and
representative gilman who have also
arrived okay uh representative gilman
we're at a point where we're
uh introducing ourselves so why don't
you go right ahead
sorry for being late mr chair i had card
trouble
um um my name's julie gilman i'm a
representative from rockingham district
18 which is the town of exeter
uh this is my third term and my third
term on this committee
and i am also a select woman in the town
of exeter so this
is a good match for me great uh
welcome back uh representative mcbride
you can unmute yourself and jump right
in
i'm you there you go is that better
that's good
yeah every mcbride 25 year veteran of
the salem board of schleckman five years
on the budget committee
second term in the house first term on
the missile
and county government and uh look
forward to
making things happen i guess very good
the last person that uh uh
did the roll call wasn't here was
representative joe guthrie's did he come
is he here yet he is not okay
thank you all right uh for the rest of
the meeting
let me just uh kind of run through the
agenda for you i should have done this
at first but
we're gonna have for the next uh
25 30 minutes we're going to have a
couple of presentations from
from what i'll call lobbyist groups one
of them the nhma and one
dupont group just as an example of what
you're
likely to hear during our regular
hearings and i've asked them to keep
their
their presentation short and topical
uh and then when that's over uh we'll
excuse them
and then we'll get into some of the
nitty gritty of of what
uh the expectations are for hearings and
executive sessions and how those are
going to work
and so forth and then i'm going to try
to get you all out of here
uh by by 11 15 11 30 at the latest so
you can go get lunch
all right so at this point uh
do we have nhma uh queued up uh
christina
yes i believe they're ready to go okay
go right ahead
all right well good morning everyone
thank you for inviting nhma
to present this morning i hope you can
all hear and see me okay
um i wanted to give a brief overview
introduce the nhma government affairs
staff
brief overview of what nhma is what we
do and then
turn it over to my colleagues for sort
of a very quick crash course
in municipal government overview of
municipal government
so my name is margaret burns i'm the
executive director at nhma
i've been with nhma about six years um
two years as executive director and
prior to that i was
a staff attorney here at nhma cordell
johnston who is also here with us this
morning is our government
affairs council he's been with nhma now
for
17 years and was previously in private
practice with oren reno
a law firm in concord nate grays
our municipal services council also in
the meeting has been with nhma for about
two years
prior to that he was a prosecutor in
northern grafton county
and finally the newest addition to our
team
is becky benvenuti our government
finance advisor
she's been with nhma only for about
eight months
but she was previously the town clerk
tax collector in newmarket
and also the revenue administrator and
tax collector
in the city of portsmouth and so we are
a small staff
a staff of nine it's important to note
that we are an
individual separate non-profit
organization
we are not a department or section of
the state
we are governed by a 25 member board of
directors
they are all municipal officials from
our member municipalities from across
the state from towns large and towns
small
cities small cities large we do have all
234 members 234 cities and towns as
members of nhma
we do not represent school districts and
although we have the cities and towns as
members of nhma
and although our advocacy is entirely
on behalf of cities and towns we do have
associate members so we do have
counties village districts and regional
planning commissions who are associate
members of our organization
our funding is primarily from the dues
that our members pay
to be members of the organization but we
do receive
some other revenue through our
publications
and the workshops and training events
that we put on for local officials
we are strictly non-partisan we are
prohibited from supporting a candidate
or a party by statute
the services that we provide sort of two
main categories we provide
the government affairs and advocacy
services but we also provide legal
services
so our members are able to contact us
and get legal advice and guidance on
matters related to municipal government
and their role in municipal government
we also provide as i mentioned
training programs on performing your
duties as a municipal official
as well as publications and educational
materials
our government affairs staff lobbies
only on matters
directly affecting municipalities and
all of the matters that we lobby on are
based on our legislative
policies and principles which are
adopted
by our members every two years and we
just adopted our most recent policies
and principles in
october 2020 for this biennium
our staff does not direct policy and i
think that's important so the positions
that we take
on certain legislation is based on those
principles and policies that our members
adopted
and directed us to take positions on
our primary concerns when it comes to
our advocacy
unsurprisingly include unfunded mandates
or any legislation that increases
municipal costs
state preemption of already existing
municipal authority
as well as any legislation that would
make
local government more difficult or more
efficient
and so generally we are here and in
other committees supporting legislation
that enables local government to operate
more efficiently
to save money to serve its citizens so
that's an overview of nhma who we are
and what we do
um and i'd like to just turn it over to
cordell and nate to talk a little bit
about
municipal government
good morning everybody uh nice to see
you all again those
those of you who those of you who i've
seen before and uh
nice to meet those of you who i haven't
seen before i'm cordell johnston
for those of you who don't know me i'm
nhma's government affairs council and
nate and i are going to give you an
insanely
short presentation about
municipal government and uh forgive us
if we if we are
being too simple i know some of you have
uh extensive experience in municipal
government
and you know all this stuff but some of
you
are relatively new to municipal
government so
as i say this is going to be extremely
brief and extremely
elementary
the basic question that i think we
all need to understand is what is a
municipality
uh and very simply a municipality
is a political subdivision of the state
it is it it's a it's an area
that has been incorporated um by the
state
and has been given authority to to act
um there are other political
subdivisions counties
school districts village districts
but we represent municipalities and
municipalities there are two
two types there are cities and towns and
those those are who we represent there
is no such thing in new hampshire as a
township
there's many years ago a member of this
committee
frequently talked about townships and it
always made me cringe
there's no such thing we have cities and
towns
nh in a few minutes is going to talk
about the basic difference between
cities and towns
uh much of what this uh committee deals
with
or pretty much everything this committee
deals with are
uh are the laws governing political
subdivisions
and a very fundamental thing that that
everyone
needs to understand is that new
hampshire is not a home rule state
which means that cities and towns do not
have inherent authority to make laws
they have only the authority that the
state gives them
in in the form of enabling statutes
so for example there's a statute that
says
a city or town can adopt a zoning
ordinance without that statute
a municipality could not enact a zoning
ordinance
and most most cities and towns have
adopted zoning ordinances there are a
few that have not
there's a statute that says you can you
can have a
police department you're not required to
and there are a few towns that don't
have police departments
there's statutes that say that cities
and towns can lay out roads
in the absence of a statute like that
you can't do it
for example if a city or town wanted to
require
drivers or passengers passengers to wear
a seat belt
they can't do that they don't have that
authority they don't have the authority
for example to impose an income tax or a
sales tax
and so a lot of a lot of times in
this committee we're dealing with issues
where
there's a question does the municipality
have the authority to do this
should we give them this a short
authority should we take away this
authority
should we modify it in some in some
respect and you'll hear us
often talking talking about a statute
being enabling
it enables municipalities to to
um adopt certain ordinances or to take
certain
actions um
there are also uh certain statutes that
create mandates
these are things that cities and towns
must do
um uh we don't have any choice about
them and a few examples
are that municipalities must conduct
state elections when every two years
when the state has an election
the municipalities are in charge of
administering those and they have to do
it
and they have to follow state law in
doing it
municipalities must provide for disposal
of solid waste
in some way or another whether it's by
having a
transfer station um collecting
trash and and uh hauling it to
a to a transfer station or uh or a
landfill somewhere
in some manner municipalities must
provide for uh solid waste
um they must provide assistance to the
indigent what is commonly referred to as
local welfare and there are a number of
other
uh mandates things that cities and towns
are required to do
um we generally like to resist
the creation of any additional state
mandates
especially if they are going to require
municipalities to spend money
unless the state is going to
provide the money to to implement those
mandates
so we will be uh sometimes in this
committee and sometimes in other
committees
uh lobbying against things that would
impose
additional mandates and especially
expensive mandates on municipalities
and another uh another thing is
preemption um where
the the state has given municipalities
authority to do something
but then take some of that authority
away
for example i talked i talked about
zoning municipalities are
enabled to adopt zoning ordinances
however the state crete has partially
preempted that
uh for example the state says that um
a municipality although you can regulate
the use of land
you can't prohibit uh agriculture
with your zoning ordinance that is
preempted you you can't prohibit
people from having accessory dwelling
units
that is preempted so those are those are
uh some of the things we'll be talking
about regularly in this committee
enabling statutes mandates preemption
the division of authority between the
state and the cities and towns
um and now nation is just going to talk
for a few minutes about the forms of
municipal government the forms of cities
and towns
well thank you cordell and as mentioned
i'm nate grays
um so one of the complications with
what all of you are going to do over the
next couple years is
deal with the forms of municipal
government there are 13 cities and 221
towns in the state and
i guess to begin with it's good to begin
with an analogy
um so typically a town
consists of the legislative body so the
voters of the town
and then a governing body which is often
the select board
but there are variations you might have
a charter town
which has uh eliminates the board of
selectmen and you have
essentially a the equivalent of a city
council
and on the city side of things often
what you have
is you have the the voters elect a body
either the aldermen or the city council
and
they serve as the legislative body much
as you you do for the state
so they make the determinations about
what the rules should be the ordinances
the policies and then that's implemented
by some some sort of
administrative officer that could be a
mayor
or it could be a mayor city manager
type situation now because there are all
these options
you often you often have to deal with
the nuances
of how this functions but the good news
is
is when we looked up where everyone on
this committee came from
um you have at least one member
from each type of of local government
so there there is that expertise
on this committee which i think will be
very useful
um because you'll be very familiar
you're obviously very familiar with with
the places you represent
well probably one of the other
complicating factors
that you'll hear a lot of talk about um
because
it is often at issue is the division
between
sb2 towns or what's called sb2 towns and
traditional towns
and so just to summarize traditional
towns have a town meeting
where the select board and other
local officials are voted on by ballot
and then they have a business session
afterwards in the business session
determines things like
town budget um and and other items
sp2 towns are different in that they
begin with a deliberative session
uh and at that session is when all the
warrant articles
are debated so basically everything
that's that's going to come up all the
legislation
and then they have their official ballot
voting day where everything is voted on
so you know whether it's a citizen
petition or whether it's something the
governing
governing body wants to discuss it's all
voted on by ballot
uh and one of the things that has been a
big issue
uh in the past couple years has been um
town meeting uh postponement obviously
we're in the middle of covid
uh so that has been a big issue as local
officials have really struggled to make
sure that
as we go forward into town meeting
season
that they can do so uh safely and so i
imagine you'll
hear from us again on what the
unfortunately named
um new uh sb2
for 2021 which involves
sort of postponing postponing town
meeting
due to covet that's really a
very brief summary of the types of forms
of government
cordow i don't know if you want to add
anything else on
i don't want to add anything other than
to say we have some uh background some
uh information um
uh some publications that we can make
available
make available to the committee and some
uh
some papers on um that describe the
different
kinds of forms of government and i will
email those to the
committee members and to the into the
committee assistant
well thank you is uh are we ready to uh
to move on from the nhma or are there
any
final comments from them
okay christina could you uh please uh
introduce
uh the dupont group
absolutely so we have commissioner wendy
piper
uh commissioner uh tom tombarello and
then we have kate horgan as well from
the dupont okay thank you
good morning chairman dolan uh my name
is kate horgan i do work at the dupont
group but part of my duties is i serve
as the executive director for the new
hampshire association of counties
which is why we are here today uh so i'm
going to turn it over
briefly to commissioner piper and
commissioner tombarello
and then i will be back to give you kind
of an overview of
what the association does so
commissioner piper take it away
good morning thank you for having us uh
and thank you
as well for the work that you do on this
committee
this committee's work is very important
to us
uh i'm a grafton county commissioner
and i'm the president of the new
hampshire association of
counties uh which is our trade
association
uh and um oh there goes that okay
something just changed uh uh what we
want to do today
is introduce you to our organization and
also briefly describe the function
of county government as kate
just explained grafton county
or we'll explain has some very important
duties
one of those is the delivery of
long-term services and supports
that is care for our elders and
also folks that
people who have developmental
disabilities people who might need to be
in our facilities
this is one of the most most expensive
obligations of new hampshire taxpayers
so your committee is an important one
along with others we'll have
representatives
here often from any of our affiliates so
our affiliates
are registers of deeds
nursing home administration
administrators and they'll
come into the state house and testify on
the impact of
any given legislation on
county government and county in other
words new hampshire
taxpayers and i just want to conclude uh
by asking you to please reach out to us
at any time
especially kate uh or tom the vice chair
or myself and also of course as laffa
pointed out she's on the her own county
executive committee
hi lafa
please talk with your own county
officials as well
thank you thanks
and commissioner tom barillo good
morning everyone
my name is tom tumbarello i'm a
commissioner here in the great
county of rockingham where i'm pleased
to say that we did testing on monday and
have
no covert cases in the nursing home or
any staff so
we really battled and battled over here
in rock
we're doing a good job to keep it out of
the nursing home so i'm on my ninth year
and i was just voted back in as the
chairman of the board second time i'll
be the chair
in nine years and your vice chairman
lives in my hometown tony
representative pia marti lives in the
great town of sandown
uh where i'm also a select one for 14
years so
i'm thrilled to get back uh into the
association as the vice president i was
also the president of that group
about four years ago so i thought i'd
follow wendy's footsteps and go
forward but i can only tell you that you
know nhac and its membership are
available to all of you folks and
i'm one commissioner if you call me or
email me i
promise you you're going to get a call
back i see that there's a a
lot of folks on your group that are
actually from rockingham county
so they've they've watched me through
the executive committee and seen that
i'm all in so uh i i just applaud you
folks and if there's anything i can do
in any way shape or form uh i'm
definitely going to be there fine i will
like i said return your call and i thank
you folks for doing everything it's such
a big
big part of county county government
work that you folks have a great
committee like that and then
heard nothing but good things about a
guy named representative tom dolan and
he has a great first name
also so we just uh got a new
commissioner
uh commissioner chieracello uh got
elected and he spoke very highly of
representative dolan so
and i i just thank you all and anything
that we can do
uh nhc is a great group and
we hope to make it bigger and better
with wendy's leadership so
i thank everybody great thank you
commissioner
um and i have shared this powerpoint
presentation with christina to share
with the rest of the committee as well
in case you want to read it in more
detail but there is also a lot of
information
listed on our website which i put on the
last slide
uh so what is county government so
county government uh
there are 10 counties in the state all
10 are members of the association
we are a multi-branch form of government
so the
county commissioners there are three in
each county represent the executive
branch
if you haven't been told already you're
the legislative branch of the county
government
also known as the county delegate you
guys are responsible for the budget
appropriations while the commissioners
handle day-to-day activities
uh some of our most uh expensive
items that we deal with are long-term
care as commissioner piper mentioned
and corrections so and we are
responsible
under state law for funding long-term
care
and supports for those uh people who are
medicaid
eligible regardless of whether or not
they are in our facilities
or fall under the cfi which is the
choices for independence waiver
and those would be the members of your
community who uh
choose to stay at home um county
corrections uh
county corrections we have people who
are awaiting pre-trial
or those who have been sentenced to less
than a year
uh for as part of their sentencing
um we also have as commissioner piper
mentioned
deeds county attorneys sheriffs county
treasurers
under our our functions
so these are our affiliates that we have
county budgets total more than 630
million dollars in the state and county
government
employs over 5 000 individuals so we are
one of the larger employers in the state
some of the work that we do on the
executive level and with state agencies
includes the department of health and
human services particularly around
medicaid
and the nursing homes department of
revenue administration
which is the real estate transfer tax
and l-chip
there's also what is called a bed tax
that we pay
on all uh that all nursing home
facilities pay
uh they pay a five percent bed tax to
the state
as part of a funding program we work
with the department of corrections the
attorney general's office
police standards and training and the
county and state finance committee which
is a committee that has
six members from dhhs six members from
county government
and uh two two members of the house and
one
member of the senate who deal with
issues that come up where there might be
disputes over
interpretations of state law uh so each
county is governed
by three commissioners
and they operate as the executive branch
they supervise all county departments
buildings lands personnel
they have budgetary oversight of all
county expenditures and responsible for
day-to-day operations
of the county so what does the
association of counties do so we
represent
at the state government level
all county employees so whether that's
nursing home employees corrections
employees deeds employees
we want to be a resource for you guys
and for our members
so we in addition to the advocacy work
that we do
provide training programs we support
intergovernmental relationships with
state and municipal officials
we come before you on a regular basis to
provide input on leadership and we act
as a clearinghouse for our members on
information and best practices to make
county government operate efficiently
so this is our leadership for 2021
you've met commissioner piper and
commissioner tom barello
our treasurer sue collins is from coast
county
kathy stacy is the register of deeds in
rockingham county commissioner pappas
is a commissioner from hillsborough
county commissioner
chuck weed he's now former commissioner
he's now become the county treasurer
is our immediate past president and
chris coats is the
county administrator for cheshire county
and
serves as our bylaws chair my last slide
just if you're looking for more
information
or we can help you here's our contact
information we're happy to help
i will say that commissioner piper did
film a video earlier this year that
includes a lot of this information
especially around your role as a
delegate to the county so if you're
looking for more information i would
encourage you
to go and check out that video um and we
are happy to answer any questions you
have now or
later so thank you so much commissioner
dolan or chairman dolan for letting us
present today
well thank you for for being here and uh
and
thank you to you and both the nhma for
keeping your presentations
brief which i know is difficult to do
thank you for doing that because we're
uh we are
about to transition in our meeting into
what i'll call the sausage making of
of our committee and so uh those of you
who are our guests
uh here uh you're free as members of the
public to
listen in or if you want to
break from the committee and and head
off for an early lunch
uh go right ahead
okay uh excuse me for the interruption
uh representative
joseph guthrie has arrived oh good
welcome joe
joe would you take yourself off mute and
uh just tell us a little bit about
yourself
uh uh your uh
how long you've been a a wrap and uh
what your experience has been
so we can you can we can all uh hear
about you a little bit okay can you hear
me now john
okay we can hear you okay i i'm uh
uh a state rep as you know in the
district uh
uh rockingham 13 which is kingston
and hampstead i'm also
a long term selectman
in hampstead and my real
old background comes from north hannover
mass i was
on a school committee and a selectman
uh there for over 19 years and
uh finally found new hampshire when i
got to be 60 years old
and retired from a t uh
i'm uh i've got uh four sons uh
i think i have 14 grandchildren and 13
great-grandchildren um probably one of
the oldest guys
outside of maybe jim mckay we fight over
when our birthday was we're both 91.
uh so um been on a health and human
services committee for a number of years
and really enjoyed
that for the last three terms and
because i'm uh
a selectman again uh i served uh
nine years and i went off my wife got
sick and
i lost her and then we came back
uh so i'm happy to be on this committee
and hope i can
contribute uh as i said i lost my wife i
was lucky to
uh fortunate to find a lovely lady
second time around
uh so we're enjoying our late retirement
well thank you joe and welcome
okay so like i mentioned we're going to
spend the rest of the meeting
uh talking about really the sausage
making of the committee there's a there
are a lot of details i'm going to try to
skip
some of these details for example the
the rules and expectations about how we
do subcommittees i don't
i don't think that's necessary to get
into that today when we have our first
subcommittee we can talk about
things like that then but i'm just going
to uh
give you an overview of what the
expectations are and what the
what the rules are and where i have
discretion and where i don't and if you
have questions during this please
exercise the
raise your hand button down below on the
bottom of your screen and
and christina will help me manage that
okay for uh one of the things that i'll
be doing
is uh and we've been asked to do is try
to organize the bills that we're going
to be reviewing
by subject matter uh and try to group
bills together that that that relate to
each other
so we'll be we'll be doing that and that
and and that will help
uh when you think about the bills that
we have in front of us
uh which are about uh somewhere between
40 and 50 at this point
the last time i checked i i counted up
39 but there was still several bills to
be assigned to
committees so i'm not exactly sure what
the number is today
but it's it is substantially less than
it was last year
i can say that i think last year we we
did about 75 bills
and a good portion of them ended up
lying on the table
uh as covet hit us and
a good a good number of them died so
we'll see some of those bills come back
this year
the whole issue about pink cards and
blue cards and people testifying
we won't talk about that because we're
not going to have a lot of in-person
testimony
uh as far as quorums go
it's not necessary for us to have a
quorum in a meeting like this
or uh where we're taking uh public
testimony the only time we have to have
a quorum is when we have an executive
session
as far as decorum goes i would ask you
to treat everybody
that especially people on the committee
uh with us or people that are about to
to testify
uh with with the respect
please address your fellow committee
members as representative
dolan or representative piamonte
and when we're in front of the public i
would ask you to try to avoid
referring to each other by your first
names uh as that
will help us with our decorum but there
is a rule about no food or drinks
other than water being consumed when the
public is present
my discretion on that is i would i will
i'll enforce the no food
but i will interpret water as
as water in its dark form
that's kind of the color of coffee or
tea
so if you have water in that form i
would allow that
um
when you ask uh people questions uh
during public testimony people who are
testifying before us
please please make sure you use that
time to get
answers to your questions that is not a
time
for for uh arguing with people that come
before us
or uh to make statements you
you when you when you converse with a
with someone giving testimony it really
should be in the form of a question
to get information about whatever the
topic is
and if if if you decide you want to make
a speech
about something one of us myself or tony
will stop you and
ask you to rethink that and see if you
can turn that into a question
now as i mentioned before we will need a
quorum
to move forward with executive session
now we have a we have a 10 to 9
population in our in our committee 10
republicans nine democrats so
we're pretty it doesn't get much more
even than that and
as you heard a lot of the opening
introductions
people mentioned how how pleased they
were about how this committee has worked
in the past
in a bipartisan way uh and i agree with
that
but let's let's let's be clear there
will be
from time to time those bills that come
up that will be partisan in nature and
ex we should expect that from time to
time there will be partisan votes
uh hopefully that is not uh
very often but it would be i think
uh wrong of me not to tell you to that
your expectation would be that that will
happen once
in a while
during during executive session that is
a time
that is for the committee
only on rare occasions would i recognize
a member of the public during an
executive session if there's a specific
issue that the committee is stuck on
and then needs clarification uh and a
public member is present
then i might i might recognize remember
from the public but
you should expect that will be a rare
thing
in executive session tabling is not
allowed so if someone makes a motion to
table a bill
an executive session that will be ruled
out of order
when you are voting an executive session
or when you are petitioning
participating in executive session
you may vote on a motion uh only if
you're
present when the question was put in
other words if you're out of the room
either in the bathroom
or taking a call or testifying in some
other committee
if the question is put to the to the
committee uh
and you return uh you will not be
allowed to vote
on that particular bill unless you're
there when the
when the uh uh motion is uh was made
if there's a conflict you you if you're
there for the entire
motion and you're in the room you will
be required to vote
in executive session unless you have
come forth before the meeting and
filed a form with the clerk
giving your intention not to vote for
whatever specific reason you have
identified
we will have amendments from time to
time an executive session on bills
[Music]
there can be as many as many amendments
as as members submit
however coming out of committee we only
can have one amendment
so that that means that if there are
multiple amendments they will have to
become
combined into one amendment
uh customarily uh
the vice chair when we take a roll call
vote the vice chair will vote first and
the chair will vote last
that's by custom
and any member of the committee can
change your vote
before the final vote is announced so if
you vote
okay to proceed and then later decide
you want to change that
to an itl vote an expedient to legislate
vote you can do that
mr chair i have a weird thing happening
i'm seeing uh representative guarino's
screen on mine it suddenly changed into
his screen so i don't know
why are you seeing uh umbrellas
no guarino marino
i'm seeing representative joseph guthrie
sorry
guthrie scheme
that's something you can you can help us
with
uh it may be that you're in um
gallery mode and let me see what i can
do
you're not
i see a screen of umbrellas too yeah
okay
i believe uh representative guthrie is
sharing his screen
okay okay thank you
here i am sorry about that i don't know
if i caused that but
sorry about that that's good that's
better
so the last point before before i leave
that just make sure you know
that if you vote in executive session
to pass a bill or to kill a bill you can
change your vote
that's up that's up to you to um make it
that wish
known to me and then we can change your
vote
now there are committee reports that um
that have to be uh published after each
executive session vote
uh the the slang for that used to be
blurbs
but we try not to use the that term
anymore but
that makes you more comfortable i
understand that's what it's about
now the committee report is supposed to
be clear concise
summary of the legislation and remember
that
if any of this legislation ends up in
court the court tends to look at those
committee reports as legislative intent
so they are important and if they're
argumentative
or inappropriate uh the speaker will
when they get to his office he'll call
them out for example if you're
in a in a minority uh writing a minority
report
and you put put something down like
you know why why is this not a good
piece of legislation well the
the legislators just lost their mind and
just voted on something stupid that that
won't be allowed to be published
uh as you would suspect so it asks you
to be
thoughtful uh write a short paragraph or
or three or four lines whatever you're
most comfortable with but be
clear concise and
and complete
okay one other thing i wanted to mention
was a couple of things
one about weapons you know that was a
rule that was
recently changed
[Music]
earlier this month to to re-allow
uh people to to carry weapons
[Music]
in the state house however
if anyone is observed brandishing
a weapon that they bring they will be uh
excused and the
sergeant of arms will be called you can
carry a weapon but you can't brandish it
or uh other words you can't show it
to somebody in in and
with that being interpreted as being a
threat
so please keep on the lookout for that
if you feel threatened or if you feel
like someone is brandishing a weapon
please
and i don't notice it please bring it to
my attention and we'll we'll deal with
it if you don't feel comfortable to
bring it to my attention in public
ask for a immediate recess and talk to
me on the side and we'll
we'll deal with that
uh tech experts uh
right now uh christina is
is managing this uh
this zoom meeting for us uh but
as you can imagine with the number of
zoom meetings being held
the number of folks that can manage them
for us
is really stretched so i'm gonna
throw it out for you to think about if
any of you
feel technically
[Music]
competent enough to take over
a zoom meeting like this and we can free
up christina to do other things
or if she's busy if she's got multiple
meetings on multiple committees to try
to
to manage we can run these uh meetings
ourselves with the
if if you if any of you feel technically
competent to do that and we can
certainly give some some short training
to get that done but
i know some some of of you struggle to
to dial your phone on one end of the
spectrum and others
are very capable uh with computers
and uh and software such as this so i'll
let you think about that
and and let me know if you'd like to be
considered as a tech expert to
to administer one of these zoom meetings
for us
if you're going to be absent you don't
have to
but i would appreciate a quick email
or a text telling me you're not going to
be able you're not going to attend
it's none of my business if it's for a
health reason but
i would just request that courtesy so
that
if i'm holding a meeting or the start of
a meeting looking for
attendance of a certain number of people
if i know you're not coming
then we can move forward and not and not
wait
so please let me know if it's a if it's
an executive session
absence uh each caucus has
their own rules about looking for
substitutes of how you how you would
engage your caucus about identifying
your absence and
whether or not a substitute will be
provided to the committee for that
executive session
so uh i would refer you
refer the democrats to representative
porter
that if if you're going to be absent i
would suspect she'll want
to know ahead of time and then and then
she can
uh decide about finding a a
with her caucus finding a substitute the
same
same thing with uh with the republicans
if
you're going to be absent please let uh
in my case let tony fiamante know and uh
we'll work about getting a substitute
mr chair i have a question sure what's
the preferred method for contacting you
uh you can you can that's a good
question
let me uh let me suggest that i'm gonna
send out
a a contact list
of all of us and what i what i'll do
is ask you to respond back to me you
know
look at it say that's okay and
or if you have a different way you'd
like to be contacted you want to be
contacted
through text to a certain cell number or
if you want to be contacted
email through your personal email or
through your state email
let me know and i'll do the same in in
my case you can contact me
text through my cell phone number or
the the state you know the dot u s uh
email address
but i'll i'll send that out in the next
day or so and
uh we're going to have some time before
we need to get together
mr chair yes hi i have a question as
well i may be
premature in asking this question um and
i
i very much appreciate you are very
clear laying out
of the rules and how it goes but i'm
wondering if you're anticipating
our committee meeting in person any time
in the future
okay great question because that was my
next topic goes
segway there you go thanks uh
right right now uh there is
uh policy still in flux
uh and i ask you to be flexible with
that i know there are a lot of people
that are concerned about meeting in
person
given the state of the virus and the
state of the vaccinations and
and so forth so
what we're going to be doing is is
typically in the past we've had
committee meetings tuesday and wednesday
and sometimes on thursday if it wasn't a
general session
i understand we're going to have
committee meetings now monday through
friday
that that will not mean that you'll be
asked to meet more often you than you
had in the past
it just means that the lob will be open
monday through friday because of the
following reason
you know that those of you familiar with
the lob
there are dividers there are hard
dividers between
committee rooms and when you pull those
dividers back
the the committee rooms become double
wide
uh and uh and so
we're gonna have we would have committee
meetings with those dividers pulled back
to to uh promote social distancing
but when you do that then
only half the committees can meet at
this at the same time if their committee
room is gone because it's
the other half is being used by another
committee so in order to
fill those slots they're gonna we're
gonna have to have
like we might be meeting for example
mondays and tuesdays
instead of tuesdays and thursdays or
thursdays and fridays
but there will be there will be a couple
of days assigned to us so we
we won't be meeting monday through
friday it's just that the lob will be
open
for meetings now as far as uh
meetings like this means uh where we're
going to have hearings public hearings
uh my understanding is that
uh that this will be primarily zoom
meetings
that those wishing to testify will
testify
through uh electronic uh means
that's going to be that is going to be
difficult i'm not sure exactly how
that's going to work or
where they're going to go to to to zoom
in
but some of us may be in
the lob but you won't be required to
come
the uh if you don't want to come to
those meetings you can
you'll be able to zoom into those
meetings uh
as far as executive session goes
the early discussion has been that
that will be different that because
you'll actually be voting during
executive session and making policy and
making
tough decisions that the original
thought was
that that those meetings should be in
person and
uh people who don't want to come would
have to ask for a substitute
uh for their absence now that's not hard
policy yet that's still in flux i
suspect
it's going to we're going to have an
option for a blended
type of meeting where people can come in
person
or they can or they can choose to uh
zoom in
but that i can tell you that that
that decision hasn't been made yet it
has a lot to do with the
from what i understand the technology
that's being uh put in place in the lobs
right now that technology
consists of some air circulation filters
that have hepa filters and have uvc
lights
in them there's what i've been told
they're supposed to
cleanse the air in the room three times
an hour and
when with those rooms opened up with
those partitions pulled down
that there's room to be seated
at least uh six feet apart it'd be every
other chair or every third chair
so but again that is policy that is
i'm still under development and uh
i don't think we've had a i don't think
the speaker's had a readout yet on the
on the technology that they're employing
and how well it's going to work and all
that stuff so i would ask you to stay
flexible with that
that hasn't been yet made yet and as far
as
our process i don't see us
having having a need to meet for the
next few weeks
uh so we we still have some time to uh
to let this policy uh uh settle in
and i'll certainly keep you posted as to
how it works out but
i suspect that uh
hearings are going to be generally zoom
meetings
and executive sessions will be blended
that's my expectation
but uh we'll we'll see i'm i'm not the
decision maker
i'm just passing on what i've heard mr
chair thank you very much for your
your long and um
interesting answer i'm just going to
tell you right up front right now
you will not be seeing me in person
until i've been vaccinated twice
that's all okay so
i i understand i'm i am eagerly awaiting
my
vaccination too anyone else ever have a
question and you have uh
representative maggiore and
representative porter with their hands
raised
okay representative imaginary thank you
mr chair
um i just and i appreciate uh i
appreciate the difficulty in trying to
navigate through all this and uh the
questions may not have
full answers so i appreciate all that
you're doing right now i'm curious
if you have right now a a uh a
target for when we might have our first
hearing or when we're gonna begin our
work
good question i i am thinking two to
three weeks from now
and uh well we'll certainly uh put put a
notice out
i'm gonna i want to wait until we see
what what bills
are coming our way uh first so uh
and then we can group them uh by subject
matter
but there isn't uh
there is until these policies settle
down a little bit
i think it's i think it makes sense for
us to wait
uh and and not try to rush things uh and
also
especially in the face of some of the
concern that people have about the virus
thank you uh was it uh
christina who is next representative
porter and then
representative manjuputi okay
representative mr
chair and uh for letting me me speak
i just want to make you aware that there
are some members of this committee
who are restricted by their doctors
from being in in a
public situation like this and would not
be able to attend executive sessions in
person
um so i just want i know you're in a
difficult situation i just
want to make you aware of that um as i'm
sure you already
are but i just want to make sure some of
us just can't come
due to living situations or health
situations if we're in person
um so it would make us heart make it
hard for us to do our jobs
okay no thank you i am aware of that and
i do appreciate it
and uh representative manjuputi
yeah this is in regards to being in
person
i am a diabetic and my doctor
strictly prohibits me from going into
any uh in-person meeting and i
also my husband is a public school
teacher
and he goes he's in person
and so i have to be very diligent and
quarantine myself
in terms of my possible exposure so
that would put a lot of constraints and
um
so i just want to let you know it's not
i want i don't want to work but
there are a lot of medical and
situational constraints
for me to be in person right i
understand that and uh thank you for
that
and by the way i i also respect
the the rules around hipaa and i i
i if anybody has a health issue
um i am not i will not
cry at you or cry about the issue i'm
really not authorized to
ask you about health issues anything you
volunteer is up to you but
please don't feel obligated to tell me
the details of
a health issue that's bothering you all
right
and i will
i'll also pass your concerns on to the
speaker
i have to stay alive to represent so
that's my constituent's request too so
yeah special elections are expensive
that's a bad uh
i just think we're gonna happen
okay uh if we have any anybody else uh
has their hand up
any questions does anybody have any
questions about what i mentioned about
the
what i call the sausage making or
weapons or
[Music]
how we deal with those testifying and
and so forth
yeah i had target at 11 15 to try to
wrap this thing up and
and we're about 11 20 so uh if anybody
doesn't have any final questions
representative powers put her hand up
and then uh representative mention okay
president powers
power thank you um chairman dolan
the question that i have as a freshman
and i was just curious to know when we
do
have hearings and executive sessions
typically how what's the duration of
either type of um meeting thank you
well that's a good question there is
there is a uh
there is a rule change uh or i don't
know if it was a rule or a custom change
uh that to try to move things along a
little quicker this year because we have
so many things that
that are going to slow us down like like
this meeting in person
probably would be uh probably
not more than half of the length of time
because it is longer when you go through
these zoom meetings
but the in executive session
we typically will schedule
in my judgment how much time it's going
to take to go through
each bill and
we can we'll often schedule them
[Music]
15 to 30 minutes apart per bill
but the the rule change or the custom
change that is authorized during this
session
is that in the previous session
we always wanted to put at least one day
between executive sessions and hearings
but this year we are authorized to
conduct an immediate executive session
if
if the uh situation warrants
for example i was talking to
representative porter about this
uh offline if we if we see a
it's apparent to us that the committee
is
pretty unanimous one way or the other
either to kill a bill or to
um support a bill
that to wait it to wait a day
uh or to wait another week uh so that it
can be published the fact that i think
that's the
that's what we did last year we waited
usually the next week
so because we wanted it to be in the
calendar a certain number of days
uh just to come back and
and to vote on something we already knew
was pretty much unanimous uh
the rule change this year is that we can
go ahead and do the executive session
immediately
i i don't think that's going to be that
many bills but
if it if it appears like that's
available to us and it speeds things up
then we can do that does that answer
your question
um in in part thank you um but i was
more looking for
when we do have an executive session um
is it typically typically gonna um
will we meet for like three hours during
that day or
is it the total length of the meeting uh
it that's really going to be driven by
the number of bills we have to exact
uh that that in our past that has gone
from one bill
uh that that for some reason uh
lagged or or was was left
to kind of clean up and we we would meet
for 20 minutes and be done
uh in other cases we've met for four
hours so
it really depends on the workload uh
and uh and what's before us so i'll
before the uh before the meeting well
before the meeting i'll i'll try to give
you a
an idea of of you know the opening and
the closing of the
of the total meeting time uh but i would
suspect that
if if we're going to come to an
executive session
that i'm going to really try hard not to
call a meeting and
especially if we're at a point where
we're meeting in person
to bring people all the way to concord
for for 15 or 20 minutes uh
try to make sure that we're going to
have a meeting it'll be a substantial
meeting
that is worth the trip
uh representative gilman has her hand up
thank you mr chair uh i was just think
uh
asking you to consider sometimes we get
a lot of a lot of written testimony
and it takes a little while to read
through it
so having an executive session
immediately after
a regular session is sometimes um
we may miss something i guess so i don't
disagree
and uh representative porter and i spoke
about about this that
if it doesn't if it's not appropriate
especially
uh if there are multiple amendments and
there are
there are other things that are
happening a written testimony like you
talked about
uh if it's not if it's not appropriate
then we won't do it
it just gives us a little more freedom
than we had before
it doesn't mean we have to exercise that
very often we can exercise it when it's
only appropriate
exercises thank you representative
mitchell poody yeah um when do we
when can we expect what days would be
allocated i know you said monday through
friday but
what day how soon can we
get that kind so that we can plan
yeah no i i appreciate that i was hoping
i'd have that for this meeting to share
with you
so i'm expecting that uh in the next few
days
uh but again i i i'm not the decision
maker i i'm waiting
to hear uh as with the the death of the
of the speaker and the new speaker
election there's been
a juggling of of assignments
and the speaker's staff you may if
you've seen
the public notice so a lot of people a
new job so
that hasn't helped making some of these
early decisions
that i was hoping to get but hopefully
as they get settled in
they'll they'll be those these decisions
will be
more readily apparent and imminent
any other questions or thoughts
one of the things that i'll say about
meeting in person i
i i learned an awful lot and
and developed
great relationships i think with members
of the committee
in the uh in the cafeteria off the
tunnel
uh and so i'm gonna miss that not
meeting in person sitting across the
table and
and uh sharing lunch with with a lot of
you
so hopefully as we can put this virus
behind us
we can get back to a more collegiate uh
relationship uh face-to-face
and uh and i i look forward to that
so any final questions before we uh
we end the meeting uh representative
amanda putin has her hand up
oh yes sorry i forgot to take it down
you answered my question thank you
okay um
um mr chair i don't have a question but
i have a comment
uh i think that you've done
a superb job of leading us on our first
zoom meeting and i look forward to your
continued leadership my one worry is
that i have to call representative pia
monte
representative pia monte and not just
pia monty
couldn't couldn't i get dispensation on
that
thank you for your great work
well if he if he puts his hat on he
becomes much more intimidating looking
so i think that's why not wearing it
right now
and as far as uh one last comment as far
as
dress code and so forth if we are in a
zoom meeting
uh i will i will just say that uh
there is no specific dress code other
than
something other than please something
other than pajamas if
he's uh please dress uh what i'll say
appropriately you know
men are required to wear ties and and uh
the uh the women are not required to
wear suits or
dresses or whatever so uh but when we
get back in person
uh i that that we'll be
using the same dress code as we use in
the in the hall of representatives
uh so uh and and representative matt
jory uh
doesn't have to wear his crown if he
doesn't want to
uh so so please uh
dress appropriately remember that we
will be zooming with the public
during these public hearings and
[Music]
and don't embarrass yourself uh or the
committee by uh what you might be
wearing or not wearing uh so uh
mr chair i have a question sure
is this how you raise your hand is there
something on the
on this on the screen down below at the
bottom of the screen
uh there's a there is a uh an icon to
push
with your with you with your mouse to
say raise hand do you see that
i don't have that no it is it is on the
participants
so you have to go under participants
wow i guess that's intuitive once you
know it
thank you okay and those of you who
zoom in on uh without the video and just
doing it like if you're in the car and
you're coming in on your phone or
whatever
uh christina can you help me is it a
star six to raise your hand
uh star six to raise your hand and star
nine to mute and unmute
okay so
so that that's much less intuitive but
uh you have to kind of memorize that if
you want if you're
if you're in your car and you're you're
driving across
the state and you're zooming in just
over your
over your telephone you can still raise
your hand but it's star six and i think
it's also
star six again to lower your hand i have
one more question
sure will there be a test at the end of
the session
yes it will be a test and the test will
be what your
contact information is so i'll send that
out to you
and uh and please uh send it back
and we'll be uh we'll be all set and
i'll make sure that you're
you're kept up to date representative
status has their hand up
sorry thank you mr chair i was trying to
unmute my audio
uh what if we want representative majori
to wear his crown
[Laughter]
all right well with that uh with that
happy note i think i'm going to end the
meeting and uh like i said
please watch your your email
and uh and update the list that i send
you make sure it's current make sure
your phone number is current and
your point of contact is current and uh
and i'll keep that on file and any
questions that
you didn't think of during the meeting
but still have please send them to me
and i'll
try to get right back to you and with
that i'm going to adjourn the meeting so
thank you
everybody thank you
it was wonderful